ce que je retiens le plus de mon premier
mandat c'est la mise en place des
conseils il faut y aller là la paroisse
le restituer aux associations aux
acteurs du quartier pour qu'ils décident
de même de ce qu'ils veulent pour les
regardiez avec la municipalité bien sûr
c'est un long combat qu'on a mené mais
un combat qui porte ses fruits
le vosgien on a plusieurs conseils
filiales installées et des associations
des acteurs qui redonne du sens et de la
victime qui vous donne une âme à nos
quartiers et pour moi ça c'est
fondamental
au delà de toutes les réalisations
matérielles mais si cette cette cohésion
humaine qui a qui convient à fort de
france qui est pour moi exceptionnel
extraordinaire alors ses réalisations
matérielles ont aussi une importance la
ville capitale
quelle quelle réalisation vous retenez
et puis où voulez vous emmener la ville
capitale demain 20 jours je retiens les
chantiers qui ont été terminés le centre
cultuel de chateauboeuf par exemple les
travaux de la rue de la liberté de la
semaine qui va qui tue et qui
aujourd'hui est un endroit
extraordinaire de cohésion de rencontres
de concerts d'animations
je retiens aussi les les travaux de
proximité dans les quartiers qui
permettent d'améliorer le quotidien
le passage à la led à l'éclairage à led
qui a démarré je suis au fort de france
dans le centre ville
mais aussi dans les quartiers je veux
que que cette ville soit davantage
solidaire davantage consolidée avec les
les hommes et les femmes qui sont
victimes d'accidents de la vie qui sont
qui perdent quelque part leur une à leur
humanité
qu'on soit davantage consolidée avec les
énigmes même si on a mis en place une
direction de la vie des aînés du côté
jonah on a mis en place un guichet
unique qui sait que maintenant nous
signé non plus que sénateur locuteurs
quel que soit le problème qui on compte
avec la municipalité quels que soient
les besoins et on va continuer ce
travail productif hors de france dans
dans l'économie du numérique dans
l'économie de l'innovation il fait un
peu que cette ville soit à nouveau un
phare dans la caraïbe et dans le monde
et qu'on continue d'innover était aussi
travailler encore parce que c'est parti
à mener sur les finances de la ville et
sur les quais les budgétaires de la
ville et sur des marges de manoeuvres
qui doivent nous permettre à bien de
répondre aux aspirations des fouilles à
l'aise et régaler mais aussi des
martiniquais et puis des problématiques
de propreté sur lesquels il faut encore
travailler faire que cette ville soit
belle et accueillante propre et on a de
vraies problématiques à ce niveau là et
puis aussi la sécurité la sécurité des
indispensables pour pouvoir évoluer
sereinement paisiblement dans le centre
ville et dans les quartiers et là on a
encore beaucoup de boulot à faire avec
l'état qui a droit à assumer toute sa
responsabilité dans cette affaire-là